كنت أدرس
قررنا الاستقالة وبدء هذا العمل
[موسيقى]
زوجتي لديها 5-6 سنوات من الخبرة
كما كان لدي معرفة فنية
دعونا ننشئ رئيسنا الخاص
قلنا أننا يجب أن نكون
بدأنا بـ 60 خلية ، لدينا 70 خلية
في المستقبل سوف يزيد و
إنتاج العسل والنحل الآخر
يصنعون منتجاتهم ويوصلونها إلى جميع أنحاء تركيا.
إذا كنت تبيع ثم تقوم بالتصدير
بالطبع ، يمكننا التركيز على الصادرات.
في ظل ظروف طبيعية تمامًا
نحن بالفعل نعلم الزراعة العضوية
أنا خريج ، أنا كليًا ضد المواد الكيميائية
لدينا بالفعل أجزاء صلبة ، لدينا وسائل النقل
نحن أجر العربة الناقل هاني
ننتقل من مكان إلى مكان بالطبع هذا نحن
إجبار
لنكن منتجين لذلك المجتمع هو منفعتنا الطفيفة
سواء كان لدينا مساهمة ، فقط للاستهلاك
ليس
[موسيقى]